[Music]
and bad customer service news submitted
by say something in Spanish please butoh
city said I just do that from a United
Airlines worker taunted a customer named
William Dix who is now suing the company
well that's your fault for having that
name come on I believe it William Dix
bill dicks Willy dick oh they mocked him
yeah this this makes me want to use
their service more names William Dix
it's like hi I'm Lauren Nick fish tits
you're not supposed to address that it's
like oh fish tits here's your ticket
like what's just like Cox
like yeah Cox is not well you wouldn't
make fun of some women yes I what did
you eat my yeah we made from quirky box
TV sounds like a porn star
absolutely reporter we made fun of Cox
cable yes you're speaking my language
exactly that's yeah I'm not saying it's
intelligent that's what we make is
nickname for Richard Richard yeah so
physically richard dicks it's dick dick
Willy
in middle initials J Willy how are they
harassing him see I like it when
companies are people too I like that
[ __ ] thanked people - I was really like
in the sense that you're you're talking
about where it's like hilarious I may
make fun of it was more like crying he
called a customer service representative
United Airlines representative to find
out information about his flight and he
was on the phone with him for 48 minutes
and apparently he was utterly humiliated
by those 48 minutes of unsolicited sex
talk by the rep what do you do this
[ __ ] phone sex up 48 minutes that's a
long freakin cult rally too long of a
joke bro it's not even funny though
representative was asking questions like
are you alone what would you do to me if
we were alone together what protection
with your girlfriend did you have a sexy
voice no apparently was a man
well did he actually call United or was
this like a hot second number cuz he
ended up giving finally after 48 minutes
he gave him information that he needed
for his flight but then he said that he
felt so humiliated after that
conversation that he felt the need to
sue and so no but it's recorded right
those conversations may be recorded for
Quality Assurance purpose what is he
suing for though like he got like is 48
minutes back you know like sexual
harassment like what kind of pricey
well humiliated just humiliated I always
loved and grown men say this [ __ ] was so
funny because he also said that that
embarrassing phone call caused his
emotional well-being and sense of
self-worth to suffer which led him to
break up with his girlfriend or what
really happened was he realized that the
man turned a mon and he's actually gay
and he's like I'm I shouldn't be in this
relation oh yeah cuz you know like those
homophobes get like really aggressive
when they're like no I'm gonna kill you
he turned me gay I don't want to kill
you yeah that's right
yeah and so uh he's suing for invasion
of privacy I don't think you should sue
he should pay him for a good time he
just gave him a 48 hour sex talk 48
minutes can I ask also why he's stealing
the [ __ ] phone if this is emotional
[ __ ] you
you know well-being is being challenged
so yeah I mean you can say a quick let
me talk to your manager
why yeah I just think this is above you
or this is inappropriate or whatever the
hell I would just have like somehow
trying to record it and then get some
free tickets first class ticket
somewhere that's all I want the idea
that I as her grown ask me I would have
to sit in a court and say my emotional
well-being was whatever the hell Mike
never gonna I think this dude just saw
doctor Gao get his ass beat and he got
it got that settlement and now he's
trying to this phone call really really
traumatize me to the point where I had
to murder my mom like the the breaking
up with a girlfriend makes no sense
exactly I think he was trying to break
up with her and he's like I'm sorry I'm
just so distressed over this United
Chloe it we can't be together and she's
like oh yeah you hurt so much might you
see them
and he's like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna make
millions I'm gonna break up with you and
I'm gonna be a celebrity man I would
love to somehow be like harassed by
encumber so I could sue them exactly
that's what this guy did yeah he stayed
on the phone for all 48 minutes that
[ __ ] when I had issues with United I was
hoping that somebody was gonna swing on
me but nothing happened Dejan deliver
yeah I don't know how this is even
possible like this is not embarrassing
to him he was also saying that like that
whole conversation reminded him of the
trauma that he suffered as a child when
he was teased because it was amazing oh
my god flashbacks exactly I was never
teased so I wouldn't know what that
feels like you want Jesus the one guy
one guy that was never teased dude my
first name is Steven with the pH and so
kids would call me step head that's not
that bad no exactly find anything
anything kids will find anything funny
you know like words you know they're
just tried to fight like rhyming words
yeah because they didn't know like
calling people gay yet and stuff yet so
they're like like that that would that
works pretty good okay ohoo step n like
you step on little chickens
[Applause]
and she's like are you like what do you
care that's the stupidest you never
heard
well if Bart said oh you kids would call
him bartender you'd be like I'm gonna
bartend I love it
kids ID if you know you're being made
fun of you're taking it very personal
yeah why you need someone there to be
like [ __ ] off my nephews used to pick on
my knees by saying you have a spider on
your head and she's like no I don't we
got in trouble because there was a
Mexican boy joined our kindergarten
class and he didn't speak English very
well and so we're like what Spanish do
we know and so a couple of kids knew how
to count to six in Spanish so we were
just talking to him to be like uno dos
tres cuatro Cinco seis but we kept
saying oh god got benched for it because
like there are you but he was happy he
was like you can't talk to him it would
be got been all the grown-ups twisted it
yeah sit down
they're probably just annoyed of the
repetitive like County students like a
male hooker now because you guys
traumatize them don't know that he's
like counting bills anymore English
penis penis penis everywhere this sounds
like a straight-up scam it doesn't sound
real I know no self-respecting she heard
of planning I just got made fun of and
she was like oh my god you know I
already have a problem cuz I'm
gender-fluid and it's like over after
that dude forget it they're saying that
they tried to contact United for a
statement but they never business exist
that's why yeah and then also like it's
unclear if the representative still
works there or not all I know is that I
hope that this guy gets robbed is there
a picture of them
he should be publicly known agreed as a
savior for all men who's been treated
and humiliated but the guy
call the wrong number and the person is
[ __ ] with him and he gave him enough
the guy gave him enough information so
the person just looked it up online and
like thousand dollars says this guy this
grown-ass man has blue here
guaran-fucking-tee wrong with blue hair
[ __ ] on guys
okay it's a new thing Lou Herrin nose
ring
exactly 100 percent nose ring I'm over
it
oh wait if you were the rep and you
found out like what this fool is trippin
over this and then you're getting sued
for this well I'm pretty sure Steve
wouldn't ask him do you [ __ ] your wife
with a condom on or something like that
but maybe make fun of I probably would
actually that that's a good question it
just depends well because I would like
to get to the real but if I'm if I'm
doing this job it's a little different
it also depends on how he got there cuz
like if they're being buddy-buddy right
and like I've never spoken to any
customer service rep and got that
personal yeah that's why he said like
you know there was this is beyond any
information that was pertaining to the
flight like why are you why was he even
calling like I've never even called
United can you do everything online and
yes like I said I'm saying people need
to just not have that job anymore
because obviously it's not working out
hey eyes have taken over I will meet
people sitting in a call center getting
so bored to the point that they're
harassing people now I see I don't know
maybe because honestly like oh god about
eight years ago I called QVC to order
some [ __ ] what and we got a little
carried away
I never ordered I was trying to get bad
these like little key necklaces I was
trying to get one of those key necklaces
for my mom yeah like the giving keys
giving kids and I will say like the lady
and me we got a little carried away in
the line I will say a guy extremely
sexual so we do that key it depends what
you want to put it oh yeah cuz the key a
key is a very like sexual thing you
think worse it's like I got the key
Dondre you know like yeah we talk did I
talk about how how I'd probably beat it
up and she said like how she probably
would like that a lot and I said okay it
was a little nasty you had a nasty time
all she was she could have been but her
voice sounded was cube you stand for
good question quality video channel
nobody knows I know HSN Home Shopping
Network yeah [ __ ] this QVC Stan value
quality value center shopping center
dude who the hell knows still around
yeah they're still around they're still
selling like diamond neck are they're
still old people dies those things
people that don't know how to use the
internet to shop yeah cuz you could buy
exact the same exact things like well
it's good like the QVC three easy
payments cheaper they have what's it
called down they had like those like
discount [ __ ] so it's like cheaper
really cuz when I see the prices I'm
like looking at I was looking for this
knife sharpener thing yeah and then I
saw on the QVC wellesley of reviews they
were they showed that video and it was
like eighty dollars cheaper on the QB CP
minimum Amazon but that was still online
yeah I was watching a YouTube video of
an old QVC review oh my god it was a
hundred like eighty dollars cheaper on
that than it was on Amazon I'll never
forget the day that my delivery man came
to the door he can hand him on my
package my mom opened it up and it was a
silver Hershey's kiss that she had got
off QVC and she's like look at it Steven
it's a silver Hershey's kiss and you can
open it and it was in that moment that I
realized my mom probably should have
died already
you mean like a sub it's like what is
your life what's left of this metals
just like a [ __ ] little bucket sits
on a desk or joy it's like when you live
for this it's like it's it's time that's
why you look at it you're like oh you're
old yeah exactly I was like oh my god
like your life's probably over right
when you raise kids it's like like you
stay at home all day and you're like you
don't talk to adults at all and you're
like oh no I just this is good right is
this good is it this is good yeah Steven
I mean she's pissed I can put little
desk trinkets in oh that would maybe
make this feel whole trinkets yeah I
think you think that's why she has just
desk trinkets in her whole [ __ ] house
she still cries oh all right love you
mom hope you hope you don't find this
one I mean you know I've done a lot of
these so plants in the neck see them she
have to really pray specifically send
this to your mother
I hope you guys enjoy this video for
more please subscribe to our Channel and
you can check out the last video right
here
[Music]